- I play basketball
but I don't play it as
well as LeBron James,
just 'cause you've hired a UX UI designer
if you don't know how to judge it fully
you might have chose the wrong one,
even if you do know how to judge it.
This portion is like with me
so I think this is one
you need to get selfish,
like you'd ask your question.
(upbeat music)
Hiring is guessing, firing is knowing.
Like you gotta go fast,
that's how you get shit done
that's how you figure stuff out.
This is the television
and the television is the radio.
It's the 4Ds motherfuckers.
Awesome.
Great.
Let's rock and roll.
What can I answer?
- Oh god, don't start with me.
I'll go second or third.
- You can only go last,
'cause then I'll skip
and we'll go around so
your choice, my rules.
- So okay.
Well I think what I struggle
with with in my business,
so I created a specializing
booking platform
specific to working with group bookings.
I think where I got a
little confused in where,
like the growth of the business,
I find that because
we're a service business
I run into where I kind of either plateau
or it's I can't hire fast
enough for the demand.
So then I just am like
kind of a sitting duck
and trying to chase, hiring more artists,
which becomes like management
like we just kind of bottle neck.
- So on that as somebody who
scaled a service business
is it hiring or is it retaining?
- It's hiring.
- And are you making
subjective calls when you hire?
- How so?
- Are you the one hiring?
- Yeah, I'm a part of the process, yeah.
- Right, so the way I ask the question
is the most important part.
I think most people struggle with hiring
because they come from a angle of fear
and when they look at hiring
they're thinking about
what they're trying to protect against
because you think that
person or this person
or that person is representing
you in this environment
and you don't want them to fuck up
in however you deem it.
You're coming from fear.
The reason I think I've been
able to scale two businesses
so quickly in my life is I'm the reverse.
I always think that if my intent is good
that by hiring quickly
I can actually scale
and that in the occasional 20% of time
when it's really actually fucked up,
my ability to fix it
out of intent and effort
is actually greater
than me judging upfront
and not hiring at all.
- So my fear what that is that
my typical client is a bride.
- Yep.
- Or a large corporate booking
and so like reputation
wise, like you get one shot.
- But you don't.
- With that particular client.
- You're not gonna see another bride again
most likely anyway.
- Right.
- And you would lose her word of mouth
and her word of mouth is only so impactful
but what you lose for is
you're not doing and scaling
out of the fear that maybe it goes poorly.
What most people struggle
with in business is
they spend all their time
on what's gonna go wrong
instead of what's gonna go right.
So yeah, big clients and brides I get it.
Good news brides don't
have great LTV, right?
And good news seven out of 10 time,
it's gonna be perfectly fine.
- Yeah.
- And good news you've hired
people that fucked up anyway.
So where I'm going with all this is
you need to hire quicker
and be more optimistic versus pessimistic.
- I think I get worried where
it's the management of both sides
and so like I built my
own booking platform
to help streamline that management
and then what I found is that
many other similar business models
that are like across the
country are struggling
with the same pain point
with not having the
right management system,
where I was able to build that,
so my question was do I
hit pivot a little or stay?
- And what, become a SAS business?
Which is fine.
You could, do you want to?
- I don't know.
- Well that's what you need to figure out,
but I will tell you that on the other side
of your service business,
it's been the clearest thing for me.
It was my hypothesis going in,
it's my natural state,
people spend all their time on defense.
What if Carl fucks up
this wedding, instead of
not thinking that,
which then leads you to hiring Carl
instead of not hiring him
because he answered one question in a way
that maybe you as a human
subjectively thought
would lead to a vulnerability.
- Well it's usually on the talent level.
It's just like the quality
of what they're able to do.
- Yeah, but you're making
that subjective call.
What you might think
is good may or may not,
I mean you've had plenty of
brides tell you this is shit
when you thought it was
great and vice versa.
Right?
I mean it's a super important
part of this question,
like you may decide that
I'm not qualified enough
but you're making a judgment
for the market without knowing.
The reason you're not hiring fast enough
is because of you.
Your subjective call.
- Not always but--
- So let's talk it through.
What would be the alternative to that?
When you say not always,
give me another scenario that's not that.
- Sometimes I actually eliminate
myself from the equation
and allow my managers and my
recruiters to make the call.
- You employ them.
- Yeah.
- That's you.
Every mistake James and
Nick Dio make is my fault.
So if you're taking
yourself out of the equation
then you're empowering people
who are saying no instead of
yes, which is still on you
is how I see it.
If you're telling me the question
that you are most worried about
which makes a ton of sense to me
because you're on it
because it is the number one
issue for service businesses
is not hiring,
that's you.
That's either you, whether
you're in the equation or not
it's still you because
you're the one that hired
the people that are making that choice.
- How would you then,
what would be maybe
the strategy to attract
maybe that ideal person of
what you're looking for?
I mean I can't just hire
everybody and anybody.
- Of course not but by
then first understanding
what ideological framework
that decision is being made on.
Once you let go of the fact that
you're making a subjective call
and so are your managers
and that they're not right,
they're making a subjective call
then it becomes easier
to say yes more than no.
I think of it as like
tie goes to the runner.
Once you change this
perspective on this conversation
you'll start saying yes a lot of times
when you would have said no in the past
and then that becomes
the fundamental unlock.
- Yeah, well I know that there's
times that I have said yes
that I would have said no
and then what we did is we created
like a supporting lead level
and then a top lead level.
So we would bring them in
like we would probably say no
but instead we've said yes
and put them on the supporting role
as opposed to like the
one that actually handled
the direct client, the main
client which is the bride,
but maybe like have them on the team.
- Bridesmaids.
- Yeah exactly and then
as they gained skill
and more experience then
we could push them up
so that allowed me to--
- So why not say yes more often now there?
- So we are starting to that
because I did change my strategy
'cause I didn't fire faster
because that was hurting us.
I think for me just being
I guess entrepreneurial
in my own mind I get
caught up as well is like
well how much can I actually scale this,
at what point do you say,
not a matter of like not
trying to meet demand,
but like it creates additional
problems in other areas
because then I don't have enough people
to manage the the concierge
part of it and courting
so like as that grows then
we're creating more problems
is it smart to just like
take what you're doing
that's working really well
and then maybe pivot in other areas?
- Well I think it becomes a question of
how much margin do you want to make?
Because one could often in those scenarios
be able to afford it except
most people have an ideology
of how much margin they
want in this given year
instead of investing it into the biz.
- Yeah, yeah.
- So that's a personal preference of
what you need to take home.
Are you caught up in the ideology
of what a SAS business is worth
versus a service business?
- A little bit.
I mean I've been in the
service business for 15 years
and I've grown it really well.
- Have you converted your
product into something
that somebody else can use?
- Not officially yet.
I'm deciding whether that's
the direction I wanna go in.
- Even in the energy that
you're bringing to the table
I think it would be worth the
risk of putting the money in
to make it so that you
can at least taste what
to other people using
the platform as a SAS.
You need the context to know.
You had 15 years to know the good
and the bad of service, right?
You know you can do it,
service business sucks.
- Right.
Or push more into it like
we're doing more corporate--
- You probably need to,
my intuition is if you can afford it
I would definitely build
out the capabilities
of the SAS product to get a couple clients
just to have the reference
point if you like it better.
- Yeah.
- Otherwise it's an unknown.
- Well I've invested so much already
in the tech side of it and now--
- Right just making front-facing
and adding the variables
tends to only be 20% of the equation.
- But the biggest thing
was when I was going to
master classes on the hair side
and I was meeting other
people just like me
that are running their businesses in Miami
and they're doing 150 weddings,
they're like how the
hell did you get to 700
and then I showed that my platform
and they're just like, that's
what piqued my interest
just for them to see that
and realize that there's
really not something like that
in the market and that's
how I was able to get
to where I'm at.
It's keeping other people that,
because I'm very passionate
about other businesses as well.
So then my personal is like
I wanna help other people
that had same pain points
and struggles I did
and then I created this--
- My perspective is that you
should run them in parallel
and build them both until
you have a data point
on the SAS business and then decide
if that's what you want to do.
- Okay, thank you.
- You're welcome.
- [Man] So, just a little
back story like I said--
- Brother started it, yeah.
- [Man] In 2016 our of
his garage selling in time
just to prove the concept
to see if there was a market there.
Four months into it, he seen that it was,
got a warehouse,
very thin employee situation.
So he's making decent money
because he didn't really
have to pay too many people,
grossed about 300 or so every year.
2018 was his biggest year, which is 327.
He saw enough of me to
take me serious enough
to take my offer to join the company,
obviously not coming in with any money
but just feeling that I
could bring some value
and raise the company up,
which I'm proud to say
that we did do that.
2019, which was my full year,
we did two three last year
and so for me the reason
I'm coming here is
we were able to do that with literally
just my muscle if you will.
Going to truck stops,
going the rest areas,
just really get out there.
- Will.
Will.
- [Man] Reviews, we have over
600 five-star Google reviews,
which on the East Coast
I've looked tire shop wise
that is a record, right?
So on the flip side I
don't understand anything
really about the social media landscape
except for the fact that
it's a huge opportunity
for distribution, I get that part,
which is why I'm here.
Obviously your team has
been great earlier today
with a lot of stuff that
we've learned so far
and so for me obviously
the personal branding
workshop that we had
obviously I feel like
there's a lot of value there
that a company like mines could get,
tagging off what Mary Dale said earlier
like in the truck tire space
I'm one of the few black
people that I know of
like nationally that does it.
We're a national provider of Michelin
so I mean it's a lot of things
that we've been able to garner in the year
that I had with him
and obviously he's happy about it
and I'm super stoked that
we're able to do it together
most importantly, right?
And so for me I just want to--
- So can I break it down for you?
- Yeah.
- On the first hot take.
Everything I just heard and an honestly
living a very similar life at some level
with a father-son dynamic,
a couple things you need
to wrap your head around.
Number one, let there be no confusion
the far majority of what
is happening in this room
and what we preach here is
about branding, not selling
and that's very tough
because when you think about
Google five star what's
so great about that is
it's transactional and that's
tangible in the short term
and a lot of what we're gonna talk about
and a lot of what we're built on,
which is really ironic
because Monica and I talk
we're in this what's
called the lower funnel,
the digital world, not the TV world
yet the juxtaposition that
I've created and debate
and completely believed to
be true is that brand is
actually built in here,
not on TV commercials.
And so challenging for an
entrepreneur is every piece of it,
like it's gonna take
you two and a half years
just to start feeling true impact
on personal brand arbitrage
that you felt immediately from
five-star reviews on Google,
which then makes nobody want to do it
because they're like fuck that.
I don't want to do that.
I fucking will keep doing
Google search Adwords
because it's transactions.
And I'm like cool you can do that,
I'll see you in seven years.
And so right off top I
think if you can run those
in parallel which is
take what you learn here
and realize okay, that's
what I'm investing in
and let me keep finding ways to transact
on what I naturally
have in my natural DNA,
I think that's a very important framework
because I think the reason
most, you know it's so funny.
From a personal brand standpoint
more than from a VaynerMedia standpoint
and I think most of you know this.
I probably say the word patience
more than any other word
and nobody wants to hear me
and that's because I build brand
and so make sure if nothing else
and I'll let you ask another question
but like brand is what
we're talking about here
and brand takes time.
- [Man] And I'm with you on that,
like that's the conversation
he and I have had
and he's like I said, really
turned the keys over to me
like from a brand plate.
- How old are you?
- 27.
- And him?
- [Man] We're 20 years apart
so he's about to be 40 in June.
Yeah.
So for me,
like we've started to now,
customers who buy eight times or more
we give them mud flaps.
A, because they have to pay for 'em.
B, it's our image on there
and our brand statement
and all that good stuff and
C, if they don't have them
then of course they get a fine from DLT.
So like things like that.
- Then you win.
- [Man] Right like so we're
all in on the brand plate
for it because I do
foresee us being able to
continue to gobble up market share,
which again like I said,
we haven't spent any money on anything
because I don't want to do anything
until I have some type of fundamental
understanding of it, right?
Facebook Ads all of
that stuff sounds great
but if you don't know what you're doing
to some degree,
I just feel like it would
be counterproductive for me.
- It is.
What's fun about it
unlike traditional media,
which is what I grew up in is
it doesn't cost a lot to learn.
You know when I had to run a TV local spot
or $40,000 full-page ad in New York Times
there was no learning.
You wrote the check and
you fucking ran the ad
and you fucking were
like holding your breath.
Facebook you can run $700 worth of ads
and learn shit.
So you're in control your spend
because you're bottom up,
you're not paying an upfront or a VIG
that's good for the media company.
So I would tell you just
even feeling you out quickly
you should do everything,
you should just do it in
100 dollar increments.
You understand?
- Yeah.
- You should know everything
at this young of an age
in this kind of level of
natural talent and curiosity
that even brought you here.
You should run ads on every platform
just a hundred bucks at a time.
That's the beauty of
the digital landscape,
you don't need to waste money.
And the learning scale,
what I learned at eight,
what I'm learning right now on TikTok
running ads against my brand
is what I'm gonna bring to
Monica as a conversation
and the truths of my
$8,000 spending a month
are gonna play out if that
brand spends eight million
because it's a marketplace,
which is powerful
so I would definitely tell you to do that.
And then for everybody, the
creative is the variable.
The math of like buying an ad is super,
you're gonna learn that awfully quick.
It's the psychology of
what pictures and videos
you put in there against who you target
to make them consider you,
that's the whole game.
- [Man] Right, lemme ask you this.
- Please, that's fine.
- [Man] So from a systemization
standpoint process
like we have it like
really super documentized
like even from video.
(coughing drowns out speaker)
We have that stuff down to the point
where on board and for our employees
all that sounds much easier now
and it's much more efficient.
And so from a scaling perspective
because we are a brick and mortar
physical retail location store.
- One, right?
- [Man] Yes, just one.
I've thought about very much so of
flirting with the idea of franchises.
- Of course.
- [Man] So because the margins are there
I feel like there's a lot
of financial implications
that are in place that I feel
like it can be sustainable
without me or us taking the risk,
not really the risk,
but taking all of that financial burden
of continuing to open up
shop after shop after shop.
- It's one of the great business models
of the last half century.
But you have a lot of in my opinion,
even just listening to
you're probably gonna want
to do some more work of
establishing the brand
because it's too early.
The first person that
takes it that isn't good
becomes a vulnerability.
No matter how many rules you put in place,
you're not in control completely.
- [Man] Yeah, okay.
- But as a business model it's
one of the greatest models
that the capitalism world has ever seen.
- [Man] Appreciate it, Gary.
- You got it, bro.
- [Man] Decided to see you again.
- Good to see you again.
- [Man] So basically I have three things
that I wanna ask and if
anybody has anything to say
you can chime in.
Number one, I was listening to,
you know I was listening
and building a name brand
which has taken me 10 years
and in the beginning was a
lot of like physical work
and everything and now
in the last few years
I've learned through like Google Ads
and Instagram I actually was doing
what you were just talking about.
I really pay attention
to what my clients like
with different events or
trends that are happening
and I put money towards those ads.
So now number one thing is--
- You were the computer kid
that I picked up along the way.
- Yeah and just like watching
a lot of people actually
like you know I should never,
I really learned by watching
and listening to people.
I'm not a big reader it's
hard for me to read a lot
so I used to like listen
up or just watch things
that I work in and trying to emulate them
to see how I can make them better.
So now I'm at a point where I geo events,
I'm trying to make it it a big brand,
doing all these corporate events,
private events in New York
but also now we have Crush Marketing,
which is a marketing company
that produces a lot of activations
and like new trends
so we could go and promote a new brand.
So my thing is like how do we take Crush
and use geo events to build Crush
and make it up, catch up to geo investors
because there's 2 different companies
that will go within each other.
- Execution about awareness.
You'll buy the output.
It's your kind of like asking like hey,
I've only built up my upper body
now I want to put muscle on my legs.
Well good news, you
have put on some muscle
on your upper body which
allows you to probably
in some of your leg exercises
be able to hold heavier dumbbells
but until you fucking do the leg exercises
it's not gonna happen.
(laughing)
It's the right analogy.
- [Man] I skipped leg week.
A week a day or whatever.
- Most people do it
doesn't have the optics.
- [Man] I know right.
Just work fast.
- But it's a very important point.
Obviously with a
intriguing kind of analogy
by just you know what people
struggle to understand is
once you establish a new brand,
look whether it's empathy or the SAS,
like you're gonna get
some level of siphoning
from what you've done in the past
but you're building your business bro.
You may not like it, I don't like it,
you're always gonna get some halo
but even the biggest
companies in the world,
Gatorade's coming out
with a new drink right now
that they have to build up
because they want to be more
than just and guess what?
They got a fucking spend and execute
and like establishing a
new brand as a new brand.
Will there be people
some like wait a minute,
I know that guy like he
did a good job, of course.
You've built a reputation
but a reputation is different than a brand
and so you're gonna have to build it.
- [Man] And one more thing is
I actually have Amazon store
that I had for like four, five years
and I just really need some guidance
on how to make it grow.
I mean, I haven't really I guess--
- Have you run Amazon ads?
- What's that?
- [Man] No, we had
somebody that works on it
but the company does okay.
It's just like treading water but--
- What products do you sell on it?
- [Man] Just T-shirts for now
but I actually want to get out of it.
I mean I jumped into it
with a friend of a friend
basically invited me as like,
you know listen, I can't
own any more stores
I want to get another store.
I see you start all these businesses,
let's to do this 50/50
and I'll show the model how to do T-shirts
and they do like over a
million dollars in T-shirts
and they have like six, seven stores.
The problem came when they noticed
that I have all this other companies
and I could also offer swag with T-shirts
at all these events
then they kind of stopped
showing me the model
of how they get to this point.
So at this point I
really need direction of
how to get a person,
somebody that could just
help me grow that store.
I had it for five years,
I know it's valuable,
I know eventually somebody
mentioned earlier,
one of the speakers that eventually
in like five, six years you know
almost everyone's gonna have a store.
That's the model, they wanna have a store.
So I had it for so long
and I feel like it's just
stuck there, you know?
- Everything about this
conversation feels wrong
because I feel like you're doing it out of
a philosophical place of like I've had it
so it I should not waste the fact that I,
like you know what I mean?
The angle of this conversation feels like
I almost without knowing
anything want you to shut it down
because I feel like you're
doing it philosophically
not because you give a fuck.
- [Man] What's the difference?
- The difference is if you're
trying to build a business
just 'cause you've had it for awhile
and the thought of it going to zero
when you feel like you've
put something into it
so thus you should,
becomes a major energy loss
against you putting that
energy to something else.
- [Man] So let it go.
- 100%.
The second you said a friend of a friend
like I was already not pumped
and they're like a friend of a friend
I was like fuck me.
(laughing)
I think you know like
if you were telling me
that you were gonna build a brand
and your deep dream was to build Off-White
or Puma or something of that nature
then I got excited.
A transactional store of
like T-shirts on Amazon
and I've had the luxury
of sitting down with you
a little bit prior to this
like I think that's a big
fucking waste of time.
- [Man] It's just like
they say, just let it go.
- [Man] Lick your wounds and walk away.
- 100%, losing is fun in the micro.
You don't wanna go
completely out of business
but like cutting something
that's bringing you very little in return
because of the philosophy of like
I don't want to take this micro L
or I've already put in this much
like people don't see the
opportunity cost issue.
- [Man] Yeah, thank you.
- [Carl] And for me mainly it's--
- For you need to monetize your voice.
Like for you no matter
what you're about to say
you should quit working with him
and start a voice business and be out.
Yeah, bruh.
For you that's that.
- [Man] Usually people
hashtag like the voice of god.
(laughing)
When we're talking or whatever
like I have different things
I deal with clients, I'm a people person,
but when he speaks,
it's like come on Carl.
(laughing)
- I feel like taking
my clothes off already.
Go ahead.
- [Man] And he undresses
you to so it's like--
- [Carl] I'm trying to keep up
I mean for me it's mainly
putting myself out there
and over thinking things
and you hit the impostor syndrome.
Social media to me is like a big giant
and I'm kind of a private
person so at the same time--
- Me too.
- [Carl] I love about the
industry that we're in,
I love the product that we put out,
clients love us, we
have a great reputation,
but for me--
- Carl, you don't have to put out anything
you don't want to.
I'm literally the most public
private person on earth.
- [Carl] In that part I
don't know how you do it.
- By not posting my kids.
Nobody knows anything
about my private life.
- [Man] Just work.
- This thought that like
it's in control is laughable.
Facebook didn't make you vote for Trump,
the Russians don't control you,
you are 100% in control
of what you put out.
People are full of shit.
Right?
People want to post pictures
of their babies and their pets
and their lives because they want likes
but good news Carl, you're in control.
- [Carl] Yeah, and I think it's me
not worrying about what others think
or me feeling that I have to
worry about that foundation.
I think that is, me getting over that.
You guys have already
helped in hearing everybody,
even you saying what you said
made me feel comfortable
and relatable to a lot
of people out there.
- Yeah, this is a judgment game.
It's a judgment game.
I's all upside.
It's a blank machine.
It's just an exposure of our inner truth.
And that's powerful because the reality is
once you realize,
I always use the example
of like when you had a zit
in junior high or high school
like you were like fuck.
Like you didn't want to go to school
like it was the worst.
And then it was just
like nobody gave a fuck
'cause everybody was
worried about their zit.
Once you get to that
basic of a level with it,
it can get really good.
People's biggest issue
is that they over value
the compliment which makes them vulnerable
to getting shit on.
The reason I've been able to cruise is
in my comments on every post literally
in back-to-back comments
there's a goat emoji
and there's a this guy took daddy's money,
he's full of shit.
Back-to-back.
And when you don't hear either
that's when you win.
Mon, got anything?
- [Mon] Sure.
This actually has nothing
to do with Budweiser.
So my life and my journey
has been completely random
but yet retro actively
kind of makes sense.
So was in the music industry before,
signed a record deal then
I became a music producer,
had some moderate success.
Exited, went back to business school,
then started working on beer
and then sort of rose to
the top within that space
and through the line I built a story
that's filled with failure
but I am comfortable with that
and in this last year I've now started
to get like some coverage on my story.
A lot of like women are like okay,
I'm the first female vice president of Bud
and all these things
so I'm starting to see
this moment or this
calling where I feel like
I want to share my story a bit more.
I started to get asked to
speak at a lot of events
now too where it's a little
bit bigger than just marketing
but it's like my point of view on on life.
So I'm kind of at that
inflection point where I'm like
figuring out if I should
be doing that or not.
- And then you're also in a big company,
which you know you have to be thoughtful
about how that works.
- [Mon] Exactly.
- I think you should be doing that.
You can always work in a company.
- [Mon] Okay.
- And then knowing
enough about your career
you're in such a great spot there too
all you have to do is
just be very thoughtful
and over communicative
and what's really cool
and it's kind of how I see,
you know it's fun I mean,
just looking at Nick and Maribel and James
they're doing things that
lets them tell their stories.
I'm a unique dude in how I structure
and I understand that I'm
not ABI or 3G or you know,
but I think finding the
right balance of how to do it
like everybody has their
confines no matter what.
Even as an entrepreneur with no board,
my confines are the market.
The market controls my outcome
but I think even like here's
the actual real answer,
just for your great-granddaughter
to consume that one day
because of the way the
internet actually works
that is an actual win to the answer.
When I started really getting
aggressive with my stuff
it was absolutely from the standpoint of
holy fuck, everybody in this room
is actually the matriarch
and patriarch of their family
because we will disproportionately
have so much more content,
pictures and videos of us
than anybody before us and in 300 years
we are like kind of
actually the starting point.
And I was just like
fuck, that's really cool
and wild and I was like fuck it.
Like that's super cool
like if nothing else
and maybe I'm affected
because I didn't know
either my grandfathers
and probably weirdly want
to and like other things
it made it very natural for me,
like if all else fails
it's a nice family thing.
Only celebrities have had the luxury
of really, really knowing
to some level even,
not even to the level that we're at.
So I think you need to do as
much of it as you possibly can.
Within the confines of yeah.
But like over communicating
upfront with the machine.
- [Man] Podcast is doing
actually really great.
- How many episodes?
- We're at 30ish.
- Okay.
- So pretty new.
- Yeah, what it's all about.
- [Man] Like top 50 management categories
so that's wicked for us.
Anyway the question is
not related to that,
so started this journey like two years ago
and then fiveish months ago figured hey,
if we could build my personal
brand with negotiations
we could probably do the
same for other executives
for people in my position.
So we started a ghost
writing/content company
about five months ago and
now we're pivoting slightly
in that we're going to market
to enterprise sales teams
to create them into thought
leaders on LinkedIn.
- I understand.
- To convert sales better.
[Man] And so one of the things
that we're struggling with
right now is we're trying to figure out,
like we're a small team
four people in a WeWork
and we're trying to figure out,
I'm trying to figure out
from a leadership perspective
how do I lead that small
team and grow that,
like how did you do it at the beginning
while still like keeping
professional/too friendly,
because they're basically like my family.
- I made them my family.
I don't think there's
anything wrong with that,
you just have to be
willing to give feedback
when somebody's taking advantage of it
instead of the reverse.
Like to me like kindness and family
and like all that stuff is the strength.
I'm at my weakest when I don't give candor
'cause I don't want to
give negative feedback
to somebody I care about and
I'm at my best when I do.
I still think it's better
than the alternative.
Even at my worst it leads
to some people quitting
or firing under bad,
I still think it's better
'cause I think 12 years later
everyone still likes each other more
than if it was just professional.
So I think it comes down to
your ability to give candor,
which is something that I struggled with
and continue to struggle with.
- It's a lot easier than it sounds.
- I'm literally pretty
public about the thing
I'm probably worst at was that
and that's cost me a lot of money
and it's also made people not like me
that I did a lot for
but because they became entitled
because I didn't give them feedback
that they weren't as good
as they thought they were
and they were feeding off of my halo.
I also think it depends
on what you're aiming for.
Without knowing his story
he clearly didn't have the leverage
enough to like in the
partnership that he had
that it led to whatever it led to
but in your scenario we're not
talking about a partnership
we're talking about employees.
And so what happened with
me in that scenario is
eventually I couldn't
hold my breath anymore
and I would fire somebody
and they would be stunned
and that led to them not liking me as much
as I could have had them love me
if I just told him a year
earlier that they sucked
and we were gonna try to figure this out.
And I've gotten better at it
but I'm still not remarkable at it
but that's all it is.
Net-net, it's a strength to
have that good of a thing.
I think the bigger issue
of what I'm hearing is
when you go into servicing
people to do something
most people don't have
the personality traits
to actually pull off what you're saying
and they're gonna blame the
service, not themselves.
So what you're going
to really need to do is
similar to what she needs to do
and what we've done here is
you're gonna have to scale more people.
- [Man] 100%.
- Which is probably gonna make
you have less margin up front
and then--
- Yeah, that's right.
- Got it?
- [Woman] Does that help
you just like learn?
- Yes.
- On who to work with
more and who to kind of--
- Yes.
And you start getting too,
I think I'm starting to
grow a little bit myself
because I'm starting to really
understand what works for me
and I'm doing a better job
communicating it upfront
to the people that I work with,
which is like hey, I'm not
gonna reach out to you.
I need you, not I'm asking you,
I need you to reach out to
me on a daily basis on text
so I have context and so I
can respond if I want to.
And if you are and for my employees
that's weird because they
don't have relationships
with the CEOs of the companies
that they've come from.
So they think they're bothering me.
- [Woman] Right, yeah.
- Three businesses.
- [Man] So basically the first question is
now we have two locations
New York and Miami
for my cleaning company
Ramon Cleaning Service
and the problem is we are
trying to scale right now.
We are kind of scaling
but and at the moment
we started realizing
that we cannot scale more
at the moment right now.
So basically we spend like for ads.
We started spending
and even though
we only see very, very small growth,
which is basically like not
giving us any more customers
mostly we focus on the
subscription-based customers.
- Well you're also investing in a platform
that's losing consumer value.
- [Man] But we're not on
here, we're also on Google.
- I'm not judging.
I'm telling you why
in a place that's declining
and its impact on the consumer
will tend to not return as much value.
It's the same thing I do
with Monica every day,
not her because she's smart
but most of her contemporaries
which is like please stop
buying regular commercials.
Like it's not going to work.
- [Man] And the other way,
we also started working with
which we can have traffic
but also is not enough as let's say--
- Another place that is
now more properly priced
so the diminishing
returns every single day
continue to decline on
the supply of consumption
and demand cycles.
- [Man] Yeah, so basically at this moment
we are trying to find a way
how we really scale and
start thinking about getting
like a PR firm to kind of get some kind of
like organic traffic more.
- Promise that's gonna be
the worst of the three.
(laughing)
Promise.
So let's talk, let's talk.
So help me one more time,
what does the business do
and what is the subscription?
- [Man] The home cleaning service.
We do residential and commercial,
but I'm now talking about the
subscription-based clients.
- Which is residential?
- [Man] Yes.
- So you're looking for us to
hire you to clean our homes.?
- [Man] Yes.
- Good and historically
has been good for you?
- [Man] Yes.
- And now it's not as good.
- [Man] Years by years it started worser
and worser and worser.
- Like everything.
- [Man] We've paying more and more money
to get every customer.
- Good news that's how every platform
in the history of marketing works.
One day when I'm older and have no hair
I'll be making fun of social media.
That's how it all works.
So what else have you done?
- [Man] Besides that we
bought some of the SEO,
like search engine optimization
but we are also getting
some traffic over there
but the competition is too high.
It's a lot of competitors basically.
- It was similar to what
I was saying to him.
The biggest decision
you're gonna have to make
in the short term is you're
gonna have to transition
to brand marketing that's smart
versus what all your energy is right now,
which is transactional marketing.
Right because it's
intent based marketing on
I need a house cleaner
in Long Island, enter,
you show up, cool I want
to out beat you, da-da-da.
When I was doing it for wine
for five cents a click, good.
Now those same words are
eight bucks, not as good.
Less people even going to search
more people deciding to buy
wine because of Instagram
and because of TikTok
and because a YouTube
and because of podcasts.
A couple things.
One, not open yet but it's for all of you
I think one of the really good ad products
that's on the verge of coming
out is a pre-roll live read,
meaning a human reads it Spotify product
that's gonna be out in
about three to six months
where you'll be able to,
like you buy Google
Adwords and Facebook ads,
put in a script that you
want podcast readers to read
and then you pay for the impressions
and people just read them
like podcast providers, makers, right?
Negotiation Ninjas can
decide to be a part of this
and when he starts his
podcast he goes Ricky's Donuts
now available and like literally live read
old-school 1950s radio at scale.
I think that's gonna be interesting
and you can run it in
New York and Miami only.
I think your business explodes
if you figure out how to
do Facebook marketing.
- [Man] Facebook?
- Mm-hmm, because
Facebook is the killer app
for 45 to 90 year olds,
which I already like from
a residential standpoint of
having the net worth to be
able to afford a house cleaner
instead of not right, instead
of doing it your fucking self.
And when you really
understand Facebook ads
and really understand how to
break down New York and Miami
into 45 to 50 different segmentations
and then what video or picture
to put in front of them
and really get good at it
Facebook will return so much more for you
then Google AdWords long term
and will build brand equity
and creates word-of-mouth
in a way that Google doesn't.
Google I type in "I need a
house cleaner in Rochester"
enter, its insular.
Facebook if you make a
really interesting ad
I may share it or I may
tag Maribelle in it.
It's inherently word-of-mouth structured
not transactional structured,
which is why it's so much more powerful.
- [Man] Okay and how about
the actual traditional PR
because you wanna also build some--
- No.
- [Man] Traffic for your brand.
Got some kind of taglines.
- What, you're gonna pay
somebody two to $8,000 a month
to get you into a magazine?
- [Man] That's something
I'm considering because--
- I'm telling you that
that's a really bad idea
but good news I'm not always right
but there's nothing
as much as I hate regular
television commercials,
traditional PR makes regular
television commercials
seem like a Jet Super Bowl.
(laughing)
- [Man] Even for proof of cost
set to go on social media,
hey, I was cover of this magazine and--
- [Woman] You can be your own PR.
- You can DM that fucking
second-rate magazine
on Instagram instead of
paying somebody eight,
four, eight, six,
I mean there's nothing
that's more overpriced
than truly traditional PR.
You could do yourself.
100%.
- [Man] Okay.
I think that's a good idea.
- Listen, what's great about
me is my first marketing budget
was $40,000 for the year,
I come from a small business place.
It's not fun to waste money.
It's gonna take you six months to realize
you wasted $24,000.
- [Man] 10 years ago
that we'll clean house
because I don't know English.
- Yeah, I get it.
- [Man] I build myself.
- I believe you and I get it
and you also paid money to be here
I really don't want you to
waste money on traditional PR.
- [Man] Thank you.
- Like what you want the Miami Herald
to say something good about you, DM them.
- [Man] I got a call
from a company there--
- Who reads the Miami Herald anymore?
- [Man] $8,000 a month
they wanna charge me
and I was having a discussion with my wife
and she's saying it's worth it
and I'm like, I'm in a position
also that it doesn't work
so it's very often--
- Have your wife call me.
(laughing)
- [Man] Have you heard of JIA?
- Mm-hmm.
(laughing)
- [Man] My second question is.
About the company I have
the roses that last a year,
the name of the company
is Jardin Deluxe Fleurs
so basically we started at the same time
and even earlier that the Venus ET Fleur,
I'm know for sure you know that.
This is our biggest competitor
but at that moment we
didn't invest it a lot
it was started as a hobby
and as soon as they started
they started as a real business
because they gave their
flowers to Kardashians.
- Okay.
- [Man] Are they real roses?
- [Man] Yeah, real roses that last a year.
- [Man] Intriguing.
- [Man] Yeah they tried to do the special,
oils it can make them last year.
So now basically the industry
that our main competitor
they made the industry.
- 'Cause they're good.
- [Man] They made it like
real roses that last year
and they even trademark it.
- That's good.
- [Man] So the biggest problem for us
during the Valentine's Day I would say
like now is Valentine's.
My team was working crazy
hard 24/7 while I'm here
but the main problem for us is
during the Valentine's time we can sell
our conversion rate is not
that high, it's like 2%.
- You mean on landing on your site?
- [Man] Yeah.
- Okay, keep going.
- [Man] It's not that
good but like considering
the average price per purchase,
which is $250 that's fine.
When they are paying like anywhere between
one to two dollars per click.
We are getting people from
Facebook and Google Ads.
- You're happy with your
CAC and LTV numbers?
- [Man] I'm not happy honestly.
And for the Valentine's Day,
it's more or less okay.
But during off season,
like last we spent like closer to $40,000.
We had a Google exclusive program
and we literally just spent that money.
We earned back like only 5K or whatever
and so it doesn't work at all.
- Well maybe your landing
page doesn't work.
- [Man] We did AB tests
and we try different pages
and like it didn't work.
- Maybe the product and the price point
didn't match the leads
that you were getting.
- [Man] No, we specifically targeted
very specific audience
because our audience is like
a high level individuals,
like COS managers.
- But you were wrong.
- [Man] I believe we
weren't wrong because--
- It is definitely wrong
because you spent $40,000
and you only got $5,000 in
sales so you're 100% wrong.
- [Man] No, but the main reason is because
we realized the year before
when we got the most of our sales,
we got it because our lead competitor
they were sold out
and that's how we got
like thousands of orders.
- Okay.
- [Man] And then the next
year we invested even more
because we survived with
a thousand supporters,
let's invest more and let sell more
and the next year then we advertise it,
our conversion rate was like
0.7 during Valentine's Day
because they still have the roses
because people actually will buy them.
- I understand.
- [Man] And then our problem
how we can make people buy from us?
- By building a brand and
by explaining to people
why your product is better
or maybe it's not, is it
better or is it worse?
- [Man] I wouldn't say it is better.
It's the same.
I would say in terms
of quality or whatever.
We just have different type of the boxes
but it's flowers, you know.
- Yeah but guess what
perception is reality.
Right, so the boxes is
part of the flowers.
The landing page is part of the flowers.
The words you use to get me
there are part of the flowers.
What you ship it in is
part of the flowers.
- [Man] So you think the real problem
is not because they
have a well known brand
but we don't have the brand,
that's why we are not selling?
- There could be a lot of things
but that's probably right.
I mean if you look at this table right now
there's literally bottles of water
that cost three fucking dollars.
We buy Fiji, is that true?
These are our bottles?
You know like that's the
stupidest shit of all time.
We're literally paying, like it's water.
What I think I'm trying
to challenge you to do is
look at the whole equation
and realize everything is part
of the customer experience
and to me clearly you have not
conveyed to the end consumer
that you're valuable the only
time anything's gone well
is when there wasn't an alternative.
That's a problem.
- [Man] But I've hired different
user experience testers
with Amazon and--
- Well the Jets have hired
football players for 50 years
and it didn't work.
- [Man] No, no but I mean like--
- No but I'm using an important analogy,
but did you hire the right people?
You know somebody the
other day said to me Gary,
but this sounds so much like the agency
we currently are using and I said maybe.
I said I play basketball
but I don't play it as
well as LeBron James.
Just 'cause you've hired a UX/UI designer
if you don't know how to judge it fully
you might have chose the wrong one
even if you do know how to judge it.
- [Man] No, I know, but that
I hired different people.
- How many?
- [Man] I would say 10 plus, 10, 15.
- You've had 10 to 15 people
work on UI UX for your site?
- No, no, no.
- Oh, I'm sorry.
- [Man] The website actually,
the website I do it by myself.
- Okay, well that's a problem.
(laughing)
I'll tell you why.
- [Man] I control it but it's Shopify.
- I understand let's talk,
when you have 2% conversion
either the things that you're
sending to the site are wrong
or what happens when you
get to the site is wrong.
There's no magic--
- [Man] But it's not about the branding,
it's not about the product?
- Yeah of course it might be
about branding and product.
That might be what's wrong on the site.
What's the site?
- I will pull it up.
- Thank you, bro.
- Yep.
- You know?
- [Man] Okay, can you tell
me your perspective on it?
- Mine's gonna be subjective
unless there's something glaring ia fuck,
which there might be
that's why I want to look at it real quick
but I think that what everybody
here has to realize is
sales is very simple,
it's you know who you send in
and what happens when they come in.
it's not super complicated.
When it's not working it's
one of those two things
or both or the product
itself to your point,
that's the only third variable.
- [Man] Because I had conversations
with a lot of different
people and actually even,
you know the PR, Runter San.
I think you know him.
- Who?
- Rauntersan, the 5WKR firm.
- Maybe, I do--
- [Man] He's from the
Russian community as well.
(laughing)
- Yeah, there's a lot of Russians
I don't know if you've heard.
(laughing)
- [Man] This is part of
the highest rated PR firm--
- I believe you.
- [Man] And I got
feedback from them as well
and it wasn't something like,
was bad on my website or something
because honestly like
when I get 30,000 people
and I get like only few orders and like--
- You might have sent 30,000
bad people to the site.
- [Man] No, because you can see it
what kind of searches they are using
and we also targeted audiences,
what kind of people we're
gonna bring on the website
and it was the right people.
- [Woman] Can I give harsh criticism?
- Of course you can.
- [Woman] Okay, so I have
received Venus ET Fleur
and I've never heard of your brand
and last Valentine's
Day my significant other
tried to buy me flowers
from Venus ET Fleur
and they were sold out so I
got it from another brand,
not your brand and I just
pulled up your website
and just on the surface, it
doesn't feel as premium as them
and I just mean that like constructively
like so some of the imagery like to me
like Venus ET Fleur
presents themselves in a way
that like it feels like
a Cartier of flowers.
It feels like a Harry Winston of flowers
and frankly like some of the imagery
and it's like the site itself
as far as like functionality
literally is structured
the same way as theirs
but I think it's like some of like--
- [Man] The quality of pictures.
- [Woman] The pictures
and then like some of the
arrangements themselves
do not feel as premium.
And I can only say that
just because I've bought--
- I was making fun of Nick.
I got the gist of what you were saying
so I moved on to make
fun of Nick, thank you.
That's their competitor, right?
- No, this is them.
- Got it.
They look fine to me.
- [Man] The website is functional.
- [Woman] No, the website itself is--
- [Man] But you're talking
about the pictures.
- [Woman] Yeah.
- It's just the presence.
- Yeah, the presence is.
- [Woman] It's just a little off.
- It's subjective and I
trust it and I appreciate it
and it's a true singular subjective
and then the issue becomes is
if the far majority agree with
her that's why you're losing.
- [Man] That could be fixed.
- [Woman] That's like a super easy fix.
- [Woman] Is this yours?
- [Man] Yes.
- [Man] This is actually
really interesting.
Have you had a focus group of women?
- [Man] Sorry?
- [Man] How have you judged--
- And are women the buyer
because I would, right.
because I would argue that
there's a very high chance
that men are the actual buyer.
- [Woman] But frankly the
only way my significant other
knew about it--
- It's because you told him.
- [Woman] I sent him on Instagram.
- Yeah, I totally get
it, I totally get it.
Like to your point is the woman
the influencer of the decision maker,
is the decision maker
not being influenced,
it's classic.
- [Woman] Well, when I got the off brand,
I was like what are these?
- Yeah, did you guys break up?
- [Woman] No.
- Oh damn.
That would've been the
best part of the story.
All right I'm gonna move on
but we'll get back to--
- [Man] So what is your opinion
because I didn't get it.
- My and Monica knows this my interest
in making a subjective
creative opinion is zero.
What I can definitely tell
you is you've got a problem.
I never take one person's opinion as truth
but if her opinion is
shared by 84% of people
you've got a problem.
Here's what I can definitely tell you,
if her feedback and the
collective vibe here
is like the imagery is not
as good as the other thing
my opinion is to hire a
very expensive photographer
and get higher, bless you.
- [Man] They have even worser images.
- No, no, you know how
people think their children
are cuter than everybody.
(laughing)
You have to be careful they
that's not your opinion
because they're your competitor.
- [Woman] I don't mean
the images themselves
I mean like some of the staging
so like that one with the champagne on it,
it feels like you're
like trying to be premium
but it's not translating.
- Go ahead, Mon.
- [Mon] Okay, I think the
first question I wanna ask you
is who are you trying to go after?
- He's a fucking businessman,
he's just trying to sell shit.
That's the problem at hand.
- [Mon] I think the
design for me right now
is like I don't know
land if that makes sense.
It's funny I didn't know that,
it's that heart shaped--
- It's also, you own this?
- [Man] Yeah.
- 100%?
Let's start with the fact
that it has 33% of his energy.
Let's just before we get
into all of our opinions
I don't know the other company
that's the market leader,
my intuition on what I hear
is that's their business.
This guy has three businesses
probably with a fourth,
fifth and sixth in his head.
That's already a problem.
- [Man] No, but my wife actually,
I had her in marketing
but she's not in control of that business.
- Understood, maybe she's not good.
- [Mon] Do you the story
of your competition?
- [Man] Yeah.
- [Mon] Like how maybe--
- [Man] I'm not exactly
what they did honestly.
- [Mon] What is it?
- [Man] I know exactly.
That's actually what has been said before,
they built a brand, that's it.
- My friend that's the
only thing that exists.
- [Woman] That's the only
reason I bought them.
- There's nothing--
- [Man] Yeah, but not for us.
It's hard to get to the
point where they are
because we don't have that money.
- Brother, they had--
- This is a little funny but
they actually have a PR agency.
- I'm sure, that's fine, that's fine.
- [Man] We called the PR agency
literally two weeks
before they signed on the,
my wife found the PR agency.
- Guys, gals, let me ask you a question.
You said that they created the category,
like they were the ones that first--
- [Man] Yes.
- Okay, let me help everybody.
When you're right about a category
you can hire my mom as your PR agent
the press picks up on an innovation.
Let's be very, it's not like
they came out with a sneaker
like when you create a category
you are forever gonna win the press game
when you're the creator of a category.
Their success is the best
thing that's happening to you.
You spending your time crying about
they have more money than
you is gonna do you nothing.
What I think you need to do
is how much Instagram posts
do you put out a day for that brand?
- [Man] Instagram posts?
- Yes, Instagram posts.
- [Man] Like whatever, one a day.
- Yeah, you better not go with whatever
because the entire target
market for your product
lives on that fucking platform.
One a day whatever is why you're losing.
Six a day knowing exactly
what the fuck you're doing
is how you can turn your business around.
- [Woman] And Pinterest.
- And on and on and on.
I'm gonna move, we'll come back.
- [Woman] Yeah, so mine is the--
- Yep.
You're in San Diego but you're global.
- [Woman] Pretty much, pretty much.
Well that's how it's going.
- Yep.
- [Woman] Like last year primarily
I was in South California
because that's where I
started and then I work
primarily a lot with
like planners and venues
because the beauty side as Ashley knows
is very personal as that goes
and so I started it
because I wanted a more
personalized experience
to like my specific needs
getting ready for events.
So a lot of it is weddings
and just like special events in general
but with that is that almost every person
that I talk to you
whether it's a new planner
or venue or stuff like that is
they're like I've never
heard of what you're doing,
which is wonderful but it's also like
how do you get--
- You don't.
You don't.
You just keep going.
People get very confused about convincing
versus communicating and moving on.
- [Woman] Okay, 'cause it
was more so is there a way
to get people to know that
you can search for this
or it's just like this steady long game.
- The execution will create the awareness.
I mean you're more than
welcome to put out creative
and content that speaks to it
but where people really get
caught up when they innovate
is trying to convince
versus create awareness.
- [Woman] That's kind of what
my gut feeling was on it.
- Like when we started
VaynerMedia like social media,
like almost every brand,
my brother AJ literally on his laptop
created the Pepsi Twitter account.
The Campbell's Facebook account
and what we were really good at
'cause it was innate in me
and now I speak to it is
we would go into a meeting
that I would get inevitably
and sometimes within four
minutes I would wrap it up
because I was like okay
this has no fucking shot.
This is somebody's taking
this meeting as a favor
that I was able to get into
but their actual interest
or even knowledge
or even thought is zero so fuck it,
I'll take back the 45 minutes
and go do something else
and people just like convinced
out of their little heart
trying to convince people
and it's a huge mistake.
- [Woman] Yeah, 'cause it's not so much
trying to convince people
it's just like the awareness of all of it
and so my feeling was
just this long game--
- It's kind of like what
I put out in the world
like you just do it
every day in perpetuity.
- [Woman] Okay, that's fine.
- I think how you do
that is important though
like this is exactly the kind of thing
that you start a podcast around
to create a pillar place
that you then create
post production content in all places
but you have a home where
literally the entire show
is about the genre.
- [Woman] Okay, thank you.
- You got it.
- [Man] You really helped
me out on my marketing,
I was just throwing things out there.
I had a guy for three years
and he was putting me on
Twitter, things of that nature,
and he went on and I
never hired anybody else.
After awhile I'm like
I need to do something
so I started educating myself
and right away I learned from you
that a lot of times people
aren't going to click
on an advertisement for an attorney
but you got to come up with
some content for them to consume
so what I did was I started
doing extreme motorcycle trips
and documenting it and
people were coming in.
We split up a brand you're a badass,
look what you're doing on the motorcycle.
They sort of think I'm doing that in court
and I would say 80%,
even though I am hitting
some home runs in court
a lot of people just hire me
because I'm in the community,
they see me, I ride,
and I've got all these videos,
lookie, I travel from the
end of the world to the top.
I mean life-threatening stuff.
- I understand.
- [Man] Okay, so I started doing that.
It's going great.
- Good.
- [Man] I want to hire two people.
where I want to be,
I want to shut down my law firm
I want to perhaps get a
desk at this other law firm
and all I do is produce, go out there,
make it rain, let them make the money,
and I get a--
- A lead gen.
- [Man] Sure, so I've got my law firm,
I got people working for me
but eventually I'm 55
maybe when I'm 65 or 70,
maybe do something like that
because I don't plan to retire.
Retirement, it's not for me.
- But you enjoyed the content--
- [Man] Hell yeah.
Oh going out there to the
bike weeks, the bike nights,
going out--
- Yeah so I mean I think the concept of
converting your business
into a top of funnel lead-gen
rev-share business that you can then push
to seven different lawyers or a hun,
as you know content on the
internet is not regional.
So now all of a sudden you've got fans
and lead-gen throughout
the entire country.
- [Man] I've got people
from South America,
Central America, Mexico, Canada--
- You probably can build a
substantially bigger business
by creating a lead gen
top of the funnel business
by taking a back-end of the
referral across the globe.
Be way happier and make a lot more money.
So the way you do that is
similar to what I said to her.
You should start the business right now.
You should create content
that alludes to it,
see what comes to you,
make a biz dev arrangement
with either somebody in South America
for all of South America or
just Brazil for just Brazil
and in essence franchise out
your top of the funnel business
and I mean you could have 50 law firms
in all 50 states as the person
that you've made the deal with to send all
because you believe they're reputable
and they know what they're doing
and they have the territory and--
- [Woman] Kind of lawyers--
- Yeah of course, of course.
- [Woman] They give you the phone number
and he's literally just funneling.
- Of course.
- [Man] Yeah, there's
about 10 of them out there
that are doing it right now.
- Lead-gen affiliate
businesses have existed
for a long time to your point
what hasn't existed is the
ability for a human being
to do exactly what they love
to garner trust and then cosign
that trust to another place.
Listen, it's really funny
in and this happens a lot
with albums and art like my first book,
even though I like The
"Thank You Economy" more,
"Crush It" will forever be
the best book I ever wrote
because I laid out this
entire truth in 2008
and it's become true.
You want to go read bad star reviews,
go read the first 500 reviews
of it on Amazon of "Crush it",
people are like fuck this guy.
This is a fucking pipe dream.
You can't make money on, what's YouTube?
Like go read them, they're hilarious.
Yeah, man.
It's there right now.
You don't the wait for 65.
- [Man] No, I understand
and to get the taste
and see if that's for
me and if I like it--
- That's right, that's
right, that's right.
Because the first time
you get a phone call
and say what the fuck, you
sent me to Karen in St. Louis--
- [Man] I'm getting that now.
Things that I don't do,
people say you just handed
me off like a cheap whore.
- [Woman] That's my problem.
Wait a second.
That's my problem.
- Same with me, they're like
you sent me to Nick Dio,
he's a fucking idiot like I get it.
- [Man] But if that's only one in 10
then I'm doing pretty good.
- Isn't that the point though?
- Of course that's the point.
Of course that's the point.
You're more than welcome
to build my dad's business
where he put my fucking cousin
and the one guy he trust
behind the fucking register
because he was scared
somebody was gonna steal,
played complete defense and then capped.
Of course that's the point.
You know why?
'Cause you can fix it.
- Because my thing is I don't
want to manage 500 artists
like I don't want that--
- You're gonna build a SAS product
and see how much you like it
and then it might be boring
because you missed the art of it
and then you won't or you will.
- Or dabble in both.
- Or dabble both.
There is no right, there's right for you.
- Right.
- [Man] Thank you for words though.
- Yep.
- [Man] The long term and
how to get there doing that
and I know you've talked about this,
maybe you might throw
something out different--
- Go ahead.
- [Man] I had the one guy--
- I got you.
You had no idea what
the fuck he was doing.
You should.
- I get three, but I wanna
start off with the first guy,
the second guy, the third guy.
And like I was telling your team
I get a lot of guys,
they know all the apps,
and I've interviewed a
few and then I stopped--
- Do you understand?
Like well you know how to judge the guy
or the gal that you hired?
Will you be able to judge the person
that's putting out the content?
- [Man] I can't answer that question
but what I am gonna do is
I'm gonna do trial and error,
like you said, fire quick, hire quick.
Just until I get the right one.
- So the you you answered
it the right way.
There's nothing to talk about here
and fire.
The more educated you are upfront,
the more you know that
you can do a poll sticker
in an Instagram story
the more likely you'll be
able to interview her or me.
- Right, 'cause right now
I'm doing it all myself
and I sat down on YouTube.
- More.
More.
I would argue that if you
went on 100 day sprint
to create content and spend
media on every platform
from Snapchat to Pinterest
to Facebook to YouTube that
that would put you in a
disproportionately better spot
to hire someone.
People trying to hire people
without knowing the craft.
How the fuck are you gonna hire somebody
like I keep telling people I'm like
I've been saying something on stage.
I'd rather you know how to do this
than balance your checkbook.
That's how important it is.
So I think 100 day sprint
on downloading them all
because inevitably you have
your favorites right now
or the one or two you feel
most comfortable with.
Get uncomfortable and
both organic and paid.
- [Man] I'm all organic
except for Facebook
because that's the older
guys on the Harleys.
Those are the one's that call me.
- Facebook and YouTube
and very quickly Instagram
are clearly going to be your pocket.
I mean YouTube pre-roll
based on Google search
that would be really good
for your business my friend,
based on both your businesses.
There's a product where
you can run YouTube videos
on a pre-roll before a video
based on what the person
was searching on Google
so it's intent-based
but it's actually brand.
So somebody's searching
to buy tires in your area
but then go watches a
Baltimore Ravens video
and you pop up and say
hey, you looking for tires,
I'm like fuck!
(laughing)
And then everyone's like
Google's searching me!
No, no, you searched for tires.
Everyone's like the phone's listening!
Nobody's, I mean it's so ludicrous.
The phone's listening.
It's not listening,
you fucking searched
for tires, you forgot.
It's like this miraculous
like everyone thinks
like fucking it's so laughable.
You searched for tires dick,
you clicked on a tires picture.
That's how they knew.
They're not fucking listening to you.
Zucks is not under your fucking bed.
Do them all for 100 days and
then started interviewing.
And ask three interesting questions.
I always say to my team I'm like look,
we're gonna lose 90% of time
because we only win with the
10 best percent of people
because we're so much smarter
and we're not gonna sell bullshit.
And that's how you want to hire.
You want to get so knowledgeable
especially at your height
of that 100 day sprint
that when you interview us and you're like
so what would you do
with Instagram swipe up?
Then you're gonna get an answer.
This is why I make fun
of everybody in my world.
I sit in rooms with people that
don't do any of this stuff.
They talk about reports and opinions.
I'm a practitioner.
Be a practitioner for 100 days
so you can ask better questions.
You'll probably do a better job of hiring.
- [Man] I'm ready to make mistakes
so I'm gonna do it.
- But don't use, to your point, exactly,
but like fuck mistakes--
- [Man] $300 here.
- Exactly and just make and just make
and just make and just a hun,
and then you'll be fucking,
you're gonna feel better too
because you're thoughtful,
you've been successful,
it's not fun to guess.
It's a lot more fun to
hire with a little, right?
So all you have to do is
make and then by the way
you may discover fuck,
I actually love this,
back to like what do you like.
Who the fuck knows what
it leads to, right?
- Marketing and scale question.
Two years ago or actually a year ago
I was a one man show, a law firm, right.
Got sick, really sick.
I was like out for six
months with Crohn's.
- Sorry.
- [Man] No worries.
So then I said look, I can't
be seen with one failure
so I started marketing for the first time
and my bread and butter right now--
- What did you market, the firm?
Or you?
- [Man] It's really more,
I'm a personal brand--
- Yeah, makes sense.
Keep going.
Good and bad news, you're
still a point of failure.
But good news,
because this is important
because it's gonna matter in a second.
You started marketing
but you're still the
point of failure, right?
But the good news is what's the punchline?
Like people all the time
they're like Gary, Vayner,
it's too much about you.
Like what if you get hit by a bus,
I'm like then it shuts down.
Whereas a good CEO for a public company
when she decides to go
work at another company
that company is actually in trouble.
So like the point of failure
conversation of a single person
is actually funny when corporate
friends of mine say that
because I'm like you do understand
that it is far more likely
for the CEO of your company
to go and work somewhere else
than it is for me to get hit by a bus.
And by the way if I get hit by a bus,
I don't give a fuck about VaynerMedia.
(laughing)
I'm dead!
I'm dead.
- [Man] I've got the team now,
so I got a team of seven.
I've got a managing partner.
I don't really wanna do the servicing.
- Yep.
- [Man] But my business
has always been like
influencer/trade show.
100% of my ad spend right now is me
going to these trade shows and I speak,
I get invited to speak on stage.
- I love it.
- That's a big one.
I have a booth and I spend--
- Top of funnel, I got it.
- [Man] A lot of travel, I
got two little kids at home,
so I started doing the digital
about eight months ago,
organic, and I'm like--
- Where?
- [Man] Facebook primarily.
- Yep.
- Loved it.
- No LinkedIn yet?
- [Man] I just started filling it.
- Good.
- [Man] So just pure value,
had no call to action
and it's working, people are recognizing--
- Go figure.
- [Man] Right, people are recognizing--
- Selfie.
They're like ah.
- [Man] Exactly, all that stuff.
I don't want to do the
trade shows anymore.
- No shit.
- [Man] No shit right,
so I want to transition
from the trade shows
to really doing digital.
- Or when you do the three
trade shows that you still value
you gotta film it so you
get a ton of content.
Beauty.
- I've done that.
- Okay, keep going.
- [Man] So the question becomes is there,
I geofence conferences now.
So I go there, I geofence,
I capture those people
who went to the conference
but I'm not there now, right?
So that's cool so I can retarget them,
so I've got that down.
The question is should
I be doing something
with those conferences
even though I'm not there?
Like running ads at those
because that's where they congregate,
that's where my client, sales congregate.
- They congregate physically there.
- [Man] Physically, correct.
- But they congregate on
the internet 24/7 365.
- [Man] So don't worry about
that my competitor's speaking
and so I got to put my face in there
even though I'm not there
just, it's just pure digital.
- That's defense.
Don't play defense.
It's a really big theme.
It really matters when I analyze from afar
who's winning and who's
losing it's offense/defense.
- [Man] Offense is usually winning?
- Yeah, I have no knowledge of anything,
like you know I loved when
James joined the organization
'cause he's like such
a career industry guy,
he has so much institution knowledge,
that was the punchline,
I wanted to extract that.
But he would talk to me nonchalantly
'cause we've been in the
business for a while enough
and he'd be like you know
Johnny Magoo from Magoo,
I'm like uh?
Like I don't know anything.
I would know that that
flower company existed
and that's where it would end.
I don't give a fuck if Rick is speaking
instead of me this year.
I stayed home because the two kids.
I'm tired.
The Crohn's thing fucked me up.
I don't wanna travel as much.
I would start a fucking call-in show
on LinkedIn every day and that's offense.
- Got it.
- Got it?
- [Man] And then how do I then transition
to more the scaling thing,
which is kind of similar to
what we we're talking about
which is so I'm top of funnel,
I bring in a crap load of leads.
I don't do a good a job with those leads,
but like I said, I'll
starting do a good job
with those leads,
then I hand off right
to the service provider,
which is my manager/partner.
She does most if not
all of the legal work.
- You have to be upfront
with the audience.
- [Man] At what point 'cause
I'm at the point where--
- Now.
- I'm taking the pitch--
Now.
You allude to them.
Look what I do with all my peeps.
As they know like I never
say you're getting me.
It's VaynerMedia.
- [Woman] But you have the credibility
to maybe pass that along.
- 100%.
100%.
- [Man] They call me, they talk to me,
I sell 'em, they're great,
they get the engagement
letter, we hire them,
then it's okay, here we go.
- Yeah, you've gotta establish that
and by the way it will always happen,
like I'm sure I've had three
conversations with Monica
through the years where
she was like but Gary,
I love you but like we love you
but like I'm sure her bosses and things
say Gary is amazing but
you know after that,
and I like I love when people like Gary,
I've had some pretty
contentious conversation
when people like Gary, listen,
like you're amazing but like the drop off
to you and your team,
it's a real problem for us
and I'm like motherfucker
the drop off for me
and anybody on earth is a problem.
The drop up for me and your
CEO is a problem, fuck you.
Don't compare me and my team,
compare VaynerMedia to
fucking your horseshit agency
that's ripping you off.
So you've got established that same truth.
- [Man] Do you announce that
on stage when you're doing--
- Yes, you start you start doing what I do
like I interject like
watch what I'm doing,
not what I'm saying.
People know there's a D-roc and a James
and a Maribelle and a Nick
like yes, that's exactly right.
- [Man] Almost bring them on stage too,
get them on video--
- Well by the way, like
I'm leaving in a minute
so you can give them all
the answers you want.
So I think the thing there
is you can bring her in
in however she wants,
she might be introverted.
Me and you might have a master plan here
in the ivory tower
and she's like don't point
that fucking camera on me
but you can speak of her existence.
You speak in team and business talk not I.
- [Man] Okay, thank you.
- [Woman] So I launched
Sluce on the app store
about six months ago, that was in July.
- Why?
- [Woman] What do you mean why?
- [Woman] Well it started off,
I don't go out too much
just because I'm super busy with racing
and I'm not really, I'm a little
more on the introvert side
so it started out because
my sister would go out
and she would go to a place
and like so we live in the
suburbs of Philadelphia--
- On the Jersey side or Philly?
- [Woman] Philly side.
- Okay.
- [Woman] So my sister would go out
and one week she would go to a place
and it would be a great time
and then she'd go there the next week
and there was nobody there
and so basically what
I was getting from her,
an app evolved a lot just
through the ideation phase.
What I was getting from her was just
like the desire for more transparency.
- Like is anybody actually there?
- [Woman] It started out that like that
and then I realized I couldn't really
scale that.
- No, yeah.
- [Woman] There wasn't
really much value there.
- It's really funny bring this up.
It was such a fun early problem
that everybody in Silicon
Valley was trying to solve
with the early iPhone
because we knew now we had something on us
and to your point that
is like the big one,
but the contradiction between what a venue
would want you to know versus,
there's so many variables
but nonetheless keep going.
- [Woman] So when we launched I had hired
a marketing agency, which
I embarrassingly admit
that I was unprepared
from my personal knowledge
of how all the platforms work.
- Of course.
- [Woman] So like I'm
like here's your budget
and I literally got
it's as close to saying
I got zero out of a six-figure budget
and like that's a hard
pill for me to swallow
because it was my responsibility
and I have people to answer to for that
and so now I like to pivot,
so we were launching
specifically in Philadelphia
and there was like a polygon
that it was allowed within
like for people to operate the app.
And for me it was like about
creating concentration.
- I understand.
- [Woman] And so we sort of extended that
now that we stopped working
with that marketing company
and we've extended to the suburbs
and the reason we did that is
because when we did our primary
pitching in Philadelphia
to get venues on board,
they're really hard
and then they don't give a shit about you.
- You didn't have the
leverage of the users.
Good news, I promise you
this if you walk into a venue
and say if I press a button
19,000 people show up,
they'll listen.
That's what I mean, you
didn't have the leverage,
keep going.
- [Woman] So we decided
that on this whole,
not that we got rid of that agency
and I'm trying to learn
some of this myself,
so I can least be versed and responsible,
we're going to the suburbs now knowing
that like they're probably going to be
slightly more receptive even to trying.
- Couldn't agree more.
- [Woman] But one of the
problems that I experienced
when I was going into the
venues in Philadelphia
primarily was about trust
and so they're like okay,
well your platforms free,
how do you make money?
And I remember the first handful of times
that I got asked that question,
it's like why do you care?
And then I started thinking
about it like from,
like had I started this idea 10 years ago,
if the technology is permitted obviously
like I was in a place where in my mind
it would've been like oh, I'm doing this
and I need to make this much money
in this much amount of time
and my folks would be
like an exit strategy
and selling or something like that
and like now like just
as I've gotten older
like I come from a very
different place of like
through me it's just about right now
building this platform out to
have value and then caring.
I already have ideas about monetization
but they're so far down the road for me
that when people ask, I'm
like who cares right now?
- Do you feel like their
energy came from a place
of the war stories of
Groupon and LivingSocial--
- [Woman] Yeah, they're
all so nasty about it.
- Of course well because
people went out of business,
which was the funniest part of it all.
Groupon and LivingSocial were so effective
people went out of business
because the people were stupid
and made offers they couldn't afford
and somehow the platform got blamed.
I'll never forget like you know,
I'm a pretty like be
accountable for your actions.
This woman's like crying in
Chicago of a cupcake store,
she's like Groupon put me out of business.
And this is like the sweetest old lady
and I'm yelling at the TV
screen in my hotel room,
brushing my teeth, I'm like motherfucker,
you put yourself out of business!
The fuck are you, what
are you talking about,
Groupon put you out of business?
- [Woman] That goes back
to the voting thing,
like you were the one that
ultimately put that out there.
- So?
- [Woman] So like with the app
I guess that one of the
struggles that we're having is
that like when we go into a venue,
right now are biggest struggle is
acquisition of these venues
and it's a very chicken and egg problem.
- Of course.
- [Woman] So like when we
go in there like right now
we're so new with onboarding these venues,
how do I garner that trust--
- It's actually similar
to three questions ago.
I think you don't have the time
or energy or scale to convince.
- [Woman] Even locally?
- Yeah, I think you just try to,
have you asked every single business?
- [Woman] No, so we just pivoted--
- You know what I mean?
Like that's where my head goes.
Here's how my head goes if
I was like the third sister
in like building this.
Ask, ask, ask, ask, ask,
you know get through a month
of asking everybody then sit
down be like fuck, all nos.
Shit, now we have to
either pick another suburb
or convince, convince,
convince but convincing...
Let me ask you a question,
so let's play it out.
I'm a gourmet food store.
Like you go to Wine Library
and we have gourmet food
because liquor's a little tricky
and I'm like hey, I like
to innovate, I'm Gary,
I like the innovate.
I'm interested in doing this.
What's the value, shit what are we asking?
- [Woman] So it's more directed
towards live essentially.
- Okay.
- [Woman] So if a restaurant was a little,
and it's not necessarily
a little on the slow side
but it's also the increased transparency
so you can put your daily specials in
and you can send out an offer.
- What are they scared of?
- [Woman] It's just like I
don't wanna deal with it.
It's too confusing.
- [Woman] I think it's
just an additional thing.
Like being a small business owner,
I owned a salon for 11 years
and like you get asked
all these different things
and you get confused on
what platform to be on.
It just becomes one more thing
to push that content to.
- [Woman] So to like fight
that argument from them,
we did Facebook integration
as like a sign up
and now we're realizing
like we want to get away
from like Facebook sign ups
because that's actually--
- Can we take a step back?
Where are you at with the business?
So like scratch.
- [Woman] I mean I used to work
in the hospitality industry
so I saw a need for like slow times--
- That makes sense.
Did that come from you want
to be the greatest hero
of the hospitality
industry or more from like
I'm in a place in my life where
I feel very entrepreneurial
and I want to do something.
- [Woman] No, I wanted to do something.
- Yeah, so I think that,
so I'll tell you why I'm going down
this series of questions.
What's really interesting
to me about this is
you're trying to create
a two-way marketplace.
The businesses that've
created two way market places
like eBay and Uber and Airbnb
are the biggest businesses in the world.
I don't think when people
go into two-way marketplaces
they realize how almost
impossible it is to pull off.
So the reason I'm asking
you the question is
in my knowledge of the
last 15 years of knowing
that you have a .0000000000000000001%
chance of building this company,
I want to make sure why are you doing it
and if it's I want to do something
because I have entrepreneurial DNA
and I'm in a position to do something
and I want to scratch that itch,
it gets to a much bigger
version of close down
your T-shirt company.
I want to make sure that you're going
eyes wide open of like fuck,
these are the hardest
businesses to build on earth.
- [Woman] So the reason I'm okay with that
and I know sort of outed
me a little earlier--
- [Man] Sorry.
- [Woman] It's okay.
I race professionally
and you follow a girl I race against
but I won't hold that against you.
- The one that came here with her family?
- [Woman] Yeah, Hailey.
- Yeah, yeah.
Okay.
So you do that.
- [Woman] Yeah, so basically
what racing has taught me
is what it takes to win.
And that's like the best thing in my life
that it's ever giving me
so to me that lesson transcends.
- It does accept what's really cool about
what you do for a living is
there's multiple races to win
whereas with a business
you're running one race
and if it's a race where
I'm racing against you
and you actually know what
you're doing and I don't,
it's highly unlikely I'm gonna win.
So for you to have the
eyes wide open of oh shit
and maybe you know it
but like for real now,
for everybody like two way marketplaces
are literally the biggest
companies in our society.
100,000 of them launch a
month and nobody ever succeeds
because the balance of
chicken-and-egg at scale.
- [Woman] It's so fragile.
- I'm gonna say it one more time.
Ebay, Uber, like you're
talking about public companies
that built, I just want
to make sure you realize
how insane of a marketplace that is.
- [Woman] I guess my hardest part is
to just get a little bit of
a traction just to start.
Like just the catalyst of it.
- Incentivize it.
- [Woman] But in what way?
- Pay small businesses to do it.
Let me tell you one thing
about small businesses
that are busy to your point,
you knock on my dad's
door and say hey Sasha,
I will pay you $2,000 to try my product
because I need the example
to sell to other people,
you will get that answer
from every one of them.
Definitely.
- [Woman] So like right now
we've been incentivizing
like I hired a photographer
that shoots for the Michelin group.
- Money.
- [Woman] Like good money?
- Nope, give them money.
They like pictures, they like money more.
Hello, Sara at the Cherry Hill Inn,
we're gonna give you a $1,000 in cash
to just try our product.
It will work.
If you're just so
itching to just taste it,
I've given you a really good answer
that's gonna save you a
fuckload of time and money
by giving them money.
You will go four for
four of giving somebody
a thousand dollars for
Saturday night to test
when you go transparent and you say,
I'm only doing this
because I need the example
to sell to everybody
else around the country,
they will understand,
it will be transparent,
and you will close deals.
- [Woman] Can you as a business
if you're paying me to do that
also if I go and share with my fans,
like hey, check us out on this platform
because we're gonna post our specials.
- Don't even ask that.
It'd be nice but then I'm saying oh,
you're paying me actually
to give you exposure.
You just need the example.
- [Woman] But I would think as a business
I would maybe potentially do that--
- I wouldn't because I'd like fuck her,
I'm gonna do that
and then she's gonna go
to another liquor store
and use my fucking customers.
That's how I got here.